my guest tonight often goes by the name
well she he is best known for his web
series Panda Q & A his retrospective on
the Saw movies and in the uncanny valley
he did a wonderful documentary called
the dark side of the internet please
welcome Matt Williams how are you I
wanna thank you very much thanks Academy
um now you technically are no longer
with that guy with the glasses calm so
why am I talking to you because you
realize I'm a replaceable and quite
frankly there's nobody better than me I
sit in that chair and interview before
but nothing had a monkey
so there might be some truth if more
people brought the monkeys maybe these
interviews would go better yeah huh
quite frankly everybody in life means a
monkey Michael Jackson had one that
brings me to my next question what's
with the monkey the monkey is out the
long version is that the very talented
very well respected my former boss Rob
Walker
yes he was nice what you say this look
the man reprimanded me which is now a
thing which is sir
fun things I've always found that the
good thing in life is that if you have
something you turn into a gimmick and
Rob reprimanded me for something that
mr. sad panda are done because clearly
we look alike he looks very very sound
alike we from the same country even
though he's French name Welsh but it
sound very similar though even the words
French Welsh it's like it's in easy mix
son robbed it for some reason
meet panda twice and reprimanded me for
something he had done which you know I
took like any mature a person would to
know when that happens so I named my
monkey after Rob and ever since then in
my videos Rob who I look after very well
as being torn hung burnt blown up and
strangled so it's my way of sort of like
showing how much i okay and respect
well she you're fired
most of the time I would say the answer
went on too long but seeing how it's
coming around to totally defacing my
brother I'm gonna let go out a little
longer
what else do you not like about Rob
Walker about wow I don't like the fact
that doing the uncanny valley segments
he tried to turn it into something about
some god damn comma thing was that we
know I can't confused me wholly I was
there for the writing I know I read the
comments like ten people were just upset
when now shut the day with him mmhmm
yeah
upset and cheerful that they were yeah
they've gone yeah I mean well what was
that what honesty what was that I I
don't know I still tried to figure out
what he is at times he's an entity that
I'm afraid to understand but the same
time can't help but question he does do
it also Palpatine impression well he
does do that very well uh with all that
said and obviously your love of video
making uh what did get you involved with
video making and what is the attraction
start off really much you
when you were doing your UTI like this
you insult my brother and then you talk
about how great I am
this is a wonderful interview I like how
this is only it's gotta be because this
is the man who's on the site you go for
your faces the site you are the site you
run the site you know I read the
Internet I hear what everyone's dentally
other people run the site but unlike
that you think I run yeah you run over
there decisions by don't you start off
with your YouTube videos and when you
got polled and then started that guy
with the glasses
I started making trailers to promote the
new NCS because at the point it was just
NCS you were doing and then Mike
michaud's and he asked me to make
trailers for everybody else and that was
my sort of foray into the editing and
then said Panda got a touch with
originated was coal guy who got in touch
with me and asked me to edit for him and
then panda got in touch meet and that's
how kinda key when they started is he'd
written the first episode of handy Q&A
and I was just this disembodied voice
off-camera and again my first appearance
and I was using at the time a very small
digital camera I didn't even have a
camcorder and that was my first
appearance on camera was in the Panda q
and A's and that was where I started
writing and that's where all that sort
of came from it was the sort of
introduction to writing shows because
panda would write the bulk of it to
begin with and then I just added my own
jokes and then it became more of a
collaboration where we throw ideas at
each other and then shaped the whole
thing around it but the fun just came
from it because it was like a hobby it
was just really fun we've been really
creative getting to work on your own
time getting to put your own content and
there was nothing more free in that
because you could say what she wanted
you could hone yourself and shape your
own sort of sense of humor and put it
all into this video and I mean the same
as that but so it's just it was
liberating to do it a lot of people
including myself have a hard time
watching our older material like when
we're first starting out do you have
that or do you not really care as much I
don't watch my old stuff there's very
few occasions i watch it and that's
usually to find something I've said
because I'm us I'm a stickler for
continuity I'm a stickler so if some
people say you know what you've said
this year but you've said this earlier I
I have a big thing about continuity so
I'll look back if I think to myself I
know I've referenced this before but I
want to make sure I myself like
maintains it of like how it all makes
sense and is the sort of one who doesn't
care about continuity at all and if
you've ever watched any founders videos
you'll know he's just like throw
everything at throw everything at the
screen and see what sticks which works
for him but that's why again we would we
work well together with the Panda Q&A
thing because he comes up with a sort of
madcap jokes I'll come up with the sort
of like to share because we when we
filmed nerd quest which was like Gervais
horror film that we felt last year I was
very much a thing about finding the sort
of character identity and so Mike had
the whole script pretty much done and
then when we did a sort of a rewrite
together
I sort of like tried to make things
consistent between characters so that
every character was that was their own
character and every character sort of
like maintained a form of continuity and
growth in the film with the dark side of
the internet that again aired with the
uncanny valley you pretty much talked
about sort of abuse online whether it be
verbal whether it go even further than
that do you think that because the
internet is still in the grand scheme of
things a very young creation that this
will pass or do you think you'll get
worse I think it'll get worse before it
gets better
because what you're gonna find is that I
mean now I don't know how it is here but
in the UK it's there's a big crackdown
now on pedophilia there's a big
crackdown on it because I think in the
laughs I'm super and sort of bullying
because in the last couple of months
pedophilia and bullying and it just so
and it's it's become a big thing and
something of this government are getting
involved in everything and it's their
sort of thing though you know they're
cranky enjoy it says typical so
government will you crack down on
something really sort of heavy
I think it'll get worse but it will get
better because it'll become that sort of
thing where it's inevitably going to be
pleased because it happens anything new
comes out you said like it's ignored to
begin with and suddenly it's so popular
then sort of the media and everything
will turn their attention to it and then
there'll be that sort of leveling out
phase where it'll still happen it'll
always happen because it
in real life but it won't be as sort of
mainstream as it is now but yeah worse
before it gets better
which is a shame but it's like it's an
edible hams with everything what is the
difference in your opinion between your
trolling and other people's trolling
because I noticed that like when people
tend to bring stuff up to you or
something don't like or they try to
trouble you you'll troll them back or
you have sort of this ongoing joke with
producers if you don't like something or
you feel there's a joke even it seems
kind of not appropriate you'll still go
for it so when you see someone else
trying to troll someone there try to get
their goat versus when you try to get
their goat no what is the difference I
can see the main difference is a lot of
times with the with the guys with the
producers I'll check first I will check
oh I never I never want to sort of and
I'll never ever do something personal or
something I will never do that it says
like you if you ever seen me troll and
producer it's never going to be about
the person it's about the producer it's
about the character they have I could
never ever do something first on me and
pander got an unwritten rule we've just
troll each other to the hills because
you know we're really good friends and
we know we know you know it's never it's
never serious when it comes to people in
the comments I'll generally do it if
because it just rolls off me I kind of
like it doesn't follow me what people
say you need a thick skin to do with
this sort of thing and if that doesn't
bother me I don't like it when friends I
have I'm close with people like film
brain I'm Annie Burke like Alison when
they get attacked I don't like it and I
will I'll do I'll do it the more out of
protection protecting us but I'll never
it'll never be like a campaign
Olivia a comment and that's it I said
forget about it I move on and it doesn't
sort of bother me again and I think the
difference with - like patrol as you get
online is they carry on they'll go to
forums they'll go to chat rooms they'll
go to videos they'll open up six or
seven accounts and they will just like
religiously go after this one person
it's just like my way you know I will
sort of like make my stand to sort of
say these this is my friend or if it's
about me personally I'll throw it into a
video and we could talk about it but
I'll never you know name the person and
then I move on and it
bother me and generally a lot of the
time is the person who did the trolling
likes the fact that I referenced them
and they then forget about it because
they saw the saying to himself oh he's
got a sense of humor it doesn't bother
him and that's it it's almost like the
best way to sort of acknowledge it
sometimes because I think Brad has does
this sort of he's done it in the past
Baylin has done it in the past as well
they just like acknowledge the sort of
comment and the Comets will stop and I
found that a lot and I've always tried
to sort of especially with Matt you've
got easier and I mean I've been speaking
about before he started faculty Pete
down and I was one of the things I
always had a said to him is don't let it
get to you and I say let him because he
is young I've always got to remind
myself that he's nothing he's 10 years
younger than me which makes me feel old
he seems to have a really good sense of
humor about that stuff like every time I
put in a role where he's gonna sort of
feel like the kiss-up or again like the
little kid or something like that like
he never has a problem with me yeah it
seems like he really relishes yes yeah
that says playing servant if he loves
playing different yes that's one thing
because I mean with a lot of the people
suddenly school kickassia
he's nothing like in his videos he loved
that he loved that he got to play
against tight because in those videos
he's very sort of well-spoken he's
articulate his analytical he's all of
those things and then in the capacity
especially he was just this you know
over excitable little boy and sort of
stuff when he knew II you never guessed
doesn't you never get to see that in his
videos and he enjoyed that you enjoyed
doing something different do you ever
find it seems like whenever you bring
something up like you say when you bring
something up with a troll or now it's a
comment they seem to stop when you do it
why do you think it is that when you can
bring out they stop up with other people
it'll continue and it'll keep going what
do you do different that other people
should maybe pick up on I think I'm
ironic about a lot of the things that
happen I mean it's it's the sort of
thing where I think it's a very British
trait there sarcasm sort of thing for
you know i'm the ione sort of thing it's
if you've ever watched space you've ever
watched ever watched space any sort of
UK show read to officer so that the
British have a very very strong sense of
irony and a lot of people don't get it
which is which is a shame because
something because I mean
I read comments what people don't know
if I'm being serious or not I mean the
whole thing with dark-sided the
Internet's I've read comments where
people didn't know if it was serious
I've got a disclaimer at the beginning
of the video saying it's serious saying
it could you know this could this could
offend certain people and it could upset
certain people but because of the
reputation I have people were still
wondering if it was serious and it's
that's a shame because in time my own
fault because I kind of built up that
that character I guess you could say of
someone who you can never really tell if
I'm being serious or not which is a
shame but it's a character I live with
now are you being serious now the monkey
is throwing me for a loop because it
sounds like you're saying serious stuff
but then I just see that monkey looking
at is crotch and I don't know what I'm
looking at or experiencing he's sorry on
the charity drive last night he was
around my neck all night it was very
scary and we did things that monkey that
thank God he can't talk because if he
could we would all be arrested yes and
the scotch tape on his arms and his legs
say a lot about what goes on behind
closed doors and we will just leave it
at that in your opinion is there a line
that you shouldn't cross whether come do
trolling or fighting trolling or any
anything online well what is the line
that you feel you should not cross if
there even is one family that's funny so
it's system if you're gonna troll
someone about the character they play or
something they've said fair enough
because you've said it but then when
people start to sort of comment on your
family or people in your lives
girlfriends boyfriends husbands widens
or stuff like that children if you've
got kids you don't you keep it you keep
it to the character that's why I said
I've never ever gone as far as
commenting on people's personal lives or
it's like when I when I make fun of Rob
Walker I'm making friend of Rob Walker
the character that is in your videos and
that's I've sort of put into my videos
now I've never made fun of Rob Walker
the man or Rob's family or stuff like
that because that's personal there's the
on camera life and then there's Dean on
camera life
the on-camera life is the sort of you
know that's the show away from that
that's personal that's nothing that's
you know that's what he goes too far and
that's you do see that you see people in
the comments they'll insult mothers
fathers I'm just thinking it was too
much too much this is like we put
ourselves on the Internet
we're opening ourselves straight up to
some form of criticism or some form of
some form of trolling but that's us
I'm come at us sort of stuff like that
but then when it's threats you know when
you get threats and death threats death
threats but people thinking I'm you run
the YouTube chat I still guys and I I am
several I should just make a folder of
like how many death threats and I will
find you stuff are in there cuz of
something either they didn't like or
they think I'm the epitome of evil or
something and something you have to know
going in like this is just gonna be a
part of it and you shouldn't be afraid
of okay from what I found a truth this
is somewhat curious ask you to do you
find that may may the people that do the
trolling and make these threats are
usually cowards usually usually I mean
there was a situation where I mean
because I kind remember it but um there
was somebody who was trolling a member
of the producer on the site and I wrote
one comment to this to this person
publicly you know so everyone could see
and he accused me of trolling him and
all I said was you know it was nothing
trolling wise it was just simply why
have you got multiple accounts cuz it
was obvious it was this person with
multiple accounts and he accused me of
trolling him and everybody jumped then
it was just like you know you know pot
kettle black and other stuff like that
and he just fit you disappeared after
that I'm just like you know if you
confess it's the same sort of thing with
bullying sometimes is you know you get
you confront them and they stop and it's
generally cowards to do it now something
you know the phrase of course your who
don't feed the trolls your proteins to
be very different you not necessary that
you feed but you confront and with you
that seems to work what again why does
it work for you and not necessarily for
others when they try to attack back is
it just the pure irony because it sounds
like you're being very straightforward
its directness as well cuz I mean
go through the same fail go through the
same valus he'll go through the same
it's it's the sort of it's the sort of
confrontational but not not an
aggressive form of confrontation it's
almost like this again is sort of like
ironic pointing out what this person is
saying and doing it in a way that just
like deflates the logic of it just like
you know they can then look at it and go
oh yeah that is oh right oh yeah and
almost like they they get that little
sort of lift out of it because they
think that that left of being referenced
you know you know you don't name them
they know you're talking to them and
they kind of like that you know sort of
thing but then you end it it's done do
you feel it's that I mean everyone
always says all they're looking for
attention and it's most of the time it
seems like that's it even if they're not
we're of it and even if it is negative
attention because sadly negative
attention is faster to get the positive
attention so you feel even though you
just acknowledge the negative attention
without necessarily feeding into it more
that usually helps a great deal yeah
well I mean you know the whole sort of
thing with a lot of the reviews we do
and you know the negative things are
always better you know because people
love to see you struggle they love to
see you sort of fight this sort of thing
and when you throw in a negative comment
about yourself and you could turn it
into something funny that's good that's
that's now that's something that's and
that's something that you could that
makes you laugh as well I mean I've had
a sort of a running sort of feud if you
want to call it with the blockbuster
Buster character because of a film he
disliked and people again were weren't
sure if I was being serious or not about
it and I had him appear in one of my
videos in a cameo which was probably one
of the most famous I must say famous but
the funniest cameos I've ever included
because it was so unexpected and people
love that and I know I love sort of I
love sort of like confusing people and
you know though I thought that they
didn't like each other and so you have
seen in the comments and I always read
those comes and get a little smile
myself because this is like you sort of
trick people into thinking it and the
first time I went to mag first was the
funniest for me because people were
coming up to me and say oh me how nice I
was and I was like
really and then I actually went back and
washed a couple of my videos I was like
oh yeah I'm not really nice on camera
just a different personality yeah it's
just uh you you sort of become this sort
of cynical sort of like sort of first
and I realized then you know I'll run
with that and then when I started doing
the second sort of like year of my
videos I ran with the whole thing of
being quite mean and cynical and that's
when the abuse of the monkey baby
started something I I always find
fascinating when I see with people and
again you I'm sure you've come across
this do you feel there is a limit to how
much you can live online as opposed to
how much you can live your life sort of
in the real world in the physical world
if there is a limit what is it and why I
think there are some mother I mean
you've seen it there are a lot of people
who live their whole lives online and I
know you need that balance you need that
sort of because it's unhealthy you know
the sort of thing it will be unhealthy
for you to just stay you know online I
think I could talk we're in a dark side
as well how people sort of become so
because you create a persona for
yourself because when you sort of hidden
not just you know on cameras or like
with a character but sometimes when you
just in chat rooms or you talk into
somebody who you never really sort of
see and you need that sort of physical
interaction with people on the outs in
the outside world you need to go out you
need friends in the real world and one
of the things you sort of see if you've
seen it but producers when they talk
about it as well they struggle sometimes
sort of like to make that connection
with people in the real world and you
need that because you don't get lost in
the sort of character or person you have
behind the camera or behind the computer
screen because that is that can be
dangerous in a sort of way because you
get lost in that and then when it comes
to actually because you're gonna have to
go at some point you can have to
interact with people at some points and
if you haven't really hold those sort of
skills you know it's gonna it's gonna
really sort of put statue of bad stead
with a lot of people and you're gonna
have trouble making friends and all sort
of thing like that and this isn't just
video producers is it no psycho on
forums and just live a very honest
like in people who do online video you
know on my video game is a sort of MMO
MMO x' and Warcraft this is than people
who just like spend you know because
they're so sometimes they are so worried
you know some of the stuff that's maybe
gone on their lives that they will go to
forums to sort of talk about their
problems but then that's it they stay
there they don't try and come up into
the real world and eventually you have
to eventually you have to because you
know you can't live online forever
no eventually you've gotta go into the
real world I've actually got to interact
with real people and that helps you
confidence more than anything talking to
people online is one thing but helping
your confidence and that's you know so
with me I've got the I've got that I've
got the divide having a real job as well
as the online hobby I've got friends
online course where than I care about my
friends and you know in real life who
like classes like my closest friends
almost like blood sisters and you've got
that so you can do one thing and you do
the other and that's the sort of
bouncers I know a lot of people do have
and you need it you do need it know what
exactly especially from someone who is
not a fan of it what is your fascination
with the Saw movies why does that have a
hold on you if anything is because it's
so personal to me be um based on my
journey while they were coming out
I'm always because at the pop I think
you can remember when - when I first saw
Kim I would torture porn Ron really a
phrase and people always say oh so it's
just torture porn I don't know the
person did it pretty well
oh yeah I agree I love lessons but the
first saw is certainly not torture
bombers they didn't have a budget for it
was worse or three is when it started to
become the sort of torture porn sort of
thing with sort of like twisted bodies
and so because they had the budget but
so from a sort of production standpoint
you talk in seven films in seven years
which was pretty impressive
it created a character in jigsaw who
primarily thanks to Tobin Bell and his
input became so iconic you know he's a
serial killer who doesn't actually kill
and told him put a lot of I'm Tobin
himself but a lot of
thought into the sort of manifestations
and thinking of the character and he is
a fascinating character which is why
even after he died spoilers he they kept
him in they kept him they kept bringing
him in and tried to feed him into the
universe but for me personally the whole
thing about saw was from saw one to saw
seven I graduated University I went
round the world I traveled I took a year
out and travel so between saw three and
so four I went around the world on my
own I just traveled it became their
tradition of me and my friend going to
see it every Halloween and very personal
things that have happened where my dog
who we had thought after quite a lot and
again I talked about hope sort of it
touches on things like self Harmer sort
of stuff which is handled very well it's
not that sort of you know graphic sort
of self-harm it's it's a very delicate
issue which is handled really well I
touch on that because I've got to some
bad things in my life and the day I saw
so six was the day my dog we put my dog
to sleep and again that was like saying
goodbye to my childhood in a sort of
waves like you know I went through all
this sort of stuff while this series was
going on it's like I talked about scream
and scream was my introduction to the
Internet
I joined my first forum ever online for
scream and that's why scream is so
important to me because it's that sort
of site of the internet for me so it's
like very very personal to me because of
the what I was going through in my life
during that seven years I actually grew
up during those 7 years say goodbye to
sort of teens that have done and became
a young adult and that's why that is so
it's so personal to me
and I love looking at the sort of
intricacies and sort of the story
because it is convoluted and it is crazy
but there is a story there and they
woven it so well that if you look at
swords 1 to 6 it's also but if you look
at sauce 1 to 6 there is a story there
and it's very very well told for what
they you know what you'd expect from a
horror film which is classed as torture
porn and forget about the story is what
brought people back and that's what a
lot of people oh because if you go to
the at the time you went to saw forms
and everything everyone was talking
about things cuz they throw in little
things that they pay off
three or four films later and they were
fans and they would visit the fan forums
to sort of see what people liked and I
think that was one of the things about
the films that was really cool as well
was the producers the directors they're
all young guys all sort of like a part
of the whole internet sort of saying
with forums and chat rooms and
everything and they don't talk to the
fans they'd go and they'll interact with
all these people and the fact it gave
the fans that sort of sense of we're in
this as well so it's a small you know
cult-like thing for saw but it's just
it's just a really sort of like cool
little franchise to be involved with now
that you are done doing videos with that
care of the glasses what are you gonna
do now
that's a minute well I'm gonna focus on
sort of like the full-time job I've got
a minute I'm still like I said I'm still
gonna be going to conventions I'm going
to Alcorn in September I'm going to
Magfest in January I'm always up for
cameos and appearances because I you
know even though I'm not with the site
anymore I'm still friends with all these
people it's just that you know the
friendships don't end just because you
move on and I've not left under a cloud
I've not left in sort of any sort of
negative way and I might even go back to
doing videos that's the thing it's just
that that at this point I'm so sort of
burnt out and Nietzsche sort of like so
really so decide where I want to go and
what I want to do I've always seen it as
a hobby that's the that's the key thing
I've always seen it as a hobby so I
could easily stand it up again
and just if something comes along this
sort of catches my attention cuz I am
one of these people who I've got to
throw myself into it hundred percent I
cannot have anything I've always been
like that I've done that every job I've
ever had once that once I start to lose
interest in the job I will either leave
straightaway which is not the smart
thing to do you want to find another job
of what you do that or you will start
looking for another job and you'll go
I've done it ever since I had a paper
round
it's the sort of thing where I love
doing the paper and as soon as I felt
that sort of I stopped I stopped and I
let my brother do it but yeah I've got
to do it you know got to be into it of a
self I still intend to work with panda
because I mean found is still right
together every time he writes a script
he'll send me the script and I'll adds
lines or say you know you should do this
so you should do that and meantime we've
got that same sort of sense of humor
which is Lucky's kind of you have you
brother where you can just sort of play
off each other and you make each other
laugh which is the sort of main thing
and we still do that and I still intend
to film a cameo with Manny buck at some
point the text has changed so which we
saw at Magfest just gone so I still tend
to do that I still tend to be sort of
presence online
I'd like to end each interview with two
polar opposite questions the first one
being what is the hardest thing
professionally or personally you've ever
had to go through and how did you get
through it personally it was probably
the as I said the death of me when my
dog got to be put to sleep because it
was this sort of irony of irony sort of
thing I was what I had the persona of
well.she at the time I was making the
trailers and I'd made a music video for
that guy with the glasses and the one of
the guys off the site on the day this
happened contacted me over Skype and
said I've got good news for you check
the site and they put my music video on
the site so I wasn't officially a part
of the site yet so as a fan it was like
you know the biggest thrill you know
you're on the site and then my mother
walks into the room and says you know
we're gonna have to put the dog to sleep
today so just like this crippling and
then I couldn't make a trailer because
my computer broke so you know on this
sort of thing where you're on the site
and then you get told
oh you're you know you put the dog to
sleep and I can't even make a trailer to
promote the fact that I've got a video
on the site for the first time and I
sort of hold a sort of character at this
point with the trailers so it was wasn't
that sort of like you know uplifting
woman and it's a real sort of like
stabbing the gut or just like oh no and
then you had a bit of work I had to work
a second half hour chef time and I had
to seesaw which is one of those things
that I'll never forget that sort of day
I got through it just because of you
know again my real sort of life there
with family and friends
they got me through that they really got
me through there and that was a very
very tough not just day
quite a few pretty hard days there and
then gone through it they got me through
it and that's the sort of thing we're
having that sort of physical contact
with people helps you they hug you and
they said let you know it's okay and
they'll let sit with you and let you
talk which you don't really get online
you wouldn't really get you know you get
people typing or voicing with you and
you hear their voice but sometimes you
need physical contact sometimes you need
someone to just sort of like sit with
you and put their arm around you and
tell you is gonna be okay and that's
what got me through it
and finally what is the one thing again
professionally or personally you are the
most proud of that you've ever done at
the minute the it's gotta be dark side
or the Internet because when I just say
that I was going to sort of step aside
I'd already been asked to do it and I
sort of made that sort of promise to
myself I'm never really happy with
anything I do but I made that promise to
myself that I was going to throw
everything I had into it and I remember
when Holly and Rob came to me and said
about it and the first thing I told them
both was I can't make it funny because I
wanted to really sort of show and I knew
it was gonna get dark because because of
the subject matter I was gonna go into
but the feedback I got from it was
probably the most gratifying because I
had a lot of I knew I was gonna get
polarizing feedback from it but I have
people coming back saying that it spoke
to them in certain ways and that was
gratifying to be able to be to be told
that I'd spoken to them and my thinking
behind the whole thing was if one person
one person who can watch this and it
makes them stop and think about their
actions and simply did write to me about
that and that that was gratifying I just
like you know it was worth it if one
person you know looked at that and
thought huh just that you know
everything anything else but that they
stopped and thought
that was when I go on
this one is shut up and talk and my
guest tonight was met Williams thank you
so much
this is where we all can't show there
and we act like we're talking you know
we're just saying face into this light
sit down yeah yeah and you know they're
gonna make this go blue and it'll be
silhouetted and we're not gonna do
anything
I don't